[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette fort aux questions ou
aujourd'hui j'accueille le docteur qui
mitent chapelle qui me bonjour et le
kymi qui nous vient de l'université du
vide bathurst rendent en afrique du sud
à johannesbourg et le docteur vincent
fernandez massant bonjour vincent qui
lui nous vient de londres du natural
history museum of london où il est le
manager du du site is khan
c'est ça c'est ça ok donc voilà une
interview du confinement mais ça
n'empêche pas la recherche d'avancer et
donc qui me et vincent vient de
contribuer à une donc vous êtes les
auteurs de cet article donc voici voici
venons ici un article qui décrit donc
des oeufs de dinosaures et pas deux pas
des yeux pas n'importe quel jeu
puisqu'ils contiennent des embryons et
que ces embryons donc nous apprennent
plein de choses sur la façon dont les
dinosaures
grandissait donc on va commencer vrai
par une question toute simple la sortie
à pâques c'est voulu grosse vous vous
avez vraiment spécifiquement demandé à
ce que ça sorte pour le week-end de
pâques à bayonne-ouest brésil face à
nous il était prévu pourquoi de début
mars au début un truc comme ça
ouais mi-mars d'accord j'ai dit on
arrête tout le monde si on pouvait
retarder de quelques semaines d'accord
donc
donc vous avez contacté spécifiquement
nature's enfin scientific report pour
demander est un pacs a pas que ça se
vendrait vachement mieux j'étais content
d'accord d'accord donc c'est pour aider
c'est le but c'est déjà parce que c'est
drôle d'image in mais c'est aussi deux
de dd un peu à la communication
ouais ouais assez de ces dommages que le
coronavirus soit passée par là quoi du
coup ils ont ils occupent un peu tout le
temps d'antenne quoi ok et ouais donc
question sérieuse
déjà va peut-être commencer par des
présentations parce que vous avez chacun
des domaines de recherche qui sont quand
même super intéressante donc honneur aux
dames j'ai envie de dire kimi est ce que
tu veux bien nous présenter un peu le
thé recherche que donc recherche que tu
as fraîchement commencé puisque tu viens
d'être nommé docteur félicitations à ce
sommet des situations publiques voilà
près de moi moi je travaille
principalement sur ma seconde iris donc
c'est un socoda morph de dates du sud et
du lesotho et du zimbabwe et pendant ma
thèse j'ai fait plusieurs choses dessus
notamment surtout je regardais la
croissance des masos pondi luce les
crânes la locomotion et c est maintenant
pour mon post doc on
je regarde un peu plus sur l'évolution
des crânes de se reposer et comment et
s'il ya une relation entre l'évolution
des craintes quand on va de death or
pendant morts jusqu'aux sauropodes
et s'il ya une relation entre ces
changements et la croissance des crânes
de massot se disent d'accord donc c'est
une étude du développement sont d'accord
et qu'est ce qu'on observe du coup sûr
ces crânes quel genre de l'instant j'en
ai aucune idée
je commençais d'accord et donc
et toi vincent tu as un expert en
technologie et toute forme de traces et
d'activités est ce que tu peux nous
parler rire mes heures perdues qu'on est
costaud ce qu'a dit tout et n'importe
quoi oui du coup c'est mes questions de
recherche sont orientés sur les terriers
possibilité d'afrique du sud
principalement et eau sur la fin du
permien ou au début du trias et
notamment regarder aux causes eurocast
les moulages de terriers
on va avoir une post la chance peut-être
d'avoir l'occupant du terrier qui a été
emprisonné comme ça avait été le cas
pour le tri naxos dont el bouroumi cet
égard je me permets de le mentionner
parce que je viens de faire une vidéo
dessus donc encore les abonnés en ont
entendu parler ya pas longtemps donc
celui qui avait fait le scan du terrier
où il y avait le l'amphi bia et le tri
naxos dans à l'intérieur ben voilà c'est
lui c'est évidemment c'est toujours un
effort collectif il n'était pas tout
seul mais voilà et donc qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que tu cherches à trouver dans
ses terriers parce que cela la question
du départ c'était parce que c'est quand
j'avais mes fait mon post doc en afrique
du sud où la question de départ c'était
si on a des animaux qui ont été piégés
dans un terrier
c'est un environnement qui a pas été
trop perturbé ya pas eu de de pain pas
de prédateurs pas trop de remaniement et
tout ça donc c'est potentiellement d
avoir une très bonne conservation et du
goût le la dans les questions de mon
post doc c'était de trouver
est ce qu'on va pouvoir trouver répondre
à des questions sur les ancêtres des
mammifères les rapides notamment sur
est-ce qu'ils étaient couverts de poils
ou pas où et comment ils se produisaient
est-ce qu'ils pondent des oeufs
est ce qu'il était au vigile par où est
ce qu'ils étaient au départ c'est
toujours des questions auxquelles on n'a
aucune raison n'a pas vraiment de
réponse et on espère pouvoir trouver ça
dans un terrier et pour l'instant on n'a
pas du tout trouvé sa maison et j'ai
plus j'essaie plus de d'orienter la
recherche sur le côté stratégie de
survie à des environnements
particulièrement inhospitalier très sec
et tous à utiliser le terrier comme on
boit plus humide
fluctuant en température et est-ce que
ça a aidé les sens et emma me faire
passer les paris des diverses crises
biologique la fin du permien d'accord et
du coup ça tu as aussi insidieusement
conduit à étudier plein neuf dates a
notamment été auteur d'une étude sur les
les plus vieux à caen qui dure c'est ça
qu'est ce que c'était bizarre hein ah
oui c'est du coup c d e 2c les sols the
de lézards avec des embryons qu'on
connaît et donc c'est ce que j'avais
utilisé étudié pendant ma thèse et c'est
justement parce que j'étudiais pas
j'avais c'est cela qui était l'objet
principal de ma thèse essayez de parce
qu'on savait pas du tout ce que c'était
il était très bizarre ces petits eux et
c'est parce qu'on n'avait jamais vu
parce que les eaux de lézards sont très
mal connus notamment dans le registre
fossile qu'on ne savait pas trop on
était un peu perturbé par eux c'est par
ces fossiles pour s'exciter des
dinosaures ou des oiseaux à la base
complètement mais du coup il ya donc
j'ai étudié cela en détails comme la
fille kimmy sur papier en sortant tous
les os un par un à la place en effet
sinon c'est gratifiant
c'était super joli quand on écrit des
notes meiway du coup c'est pour essayer
de valider la technique j'ai scanné
plein de notes et des oeufs avec on
savait pas s'ils avaient quelque chose d
eux savaient que quelque chose
différents types de préservation et
c'était pour voir
est-ce que la technique qu'on utilise au
synchrotron marche tout le temps et est
ce que est ce qu'on pourrait trop est ce
qu'on a
est ce qu'elle arrive à résoudre des cas
où on n'arrive pas à les scanner les
yeux avec des machines de laboratoire et
du coup c'est j'ai commencé par ça et
parce que j'ai étudié il faut aussi lui
qui a été caché dans dans des oeufs que
ça a donné l'idée à vous
by de l'université du ve a dû attendre
de me prendre un post doc pour faire la
même chose mais plus grands trouver des
animaux qui étaient cachés dans dans
leur moulage de terriers d'accord
d'accord puisque tu as mentionné les
oeufs embryonnés on va je vais poser la
question à kimi qu est ce qu on a donc
là tu as des cris dé nouveau enfin des
nouveaux n'ont pas spécialement nouveau
ça faisait depuis les années 70 c'est ça
qu'on les avait découverts cce de ma
sauce pon di luce donc c'est pas
spécialement nouveau mais c'est
l'application de la technique de scan
par synchrotron qui est nouvelle qui t'a
permis de voir ces embryons avec un oeil
nouveau
si je puis dire du coup qu'est-ce qu'on
a qu'est ce qu'on connaît à propos des
oeufs de dinosaures parce que c'est
enfin je sais pas quand on parle de
dinosaures on visualise évidemment on
visualise d'abord jurassic park
ok mais voilà qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on
sait de des oeufs de dinosaures en fait
voilà et en quoi ça c'est juste pour
remettre en contexte en quoi ce que tu
as fait apporte finalement déjà à ce
qu'on connaissait avant donc en général
sur les dinosaures tu veux dire ou bien
sûr c'est aussi en particulier bah ouais
en général d'abord qu'est-ce qu'on est
ce qu'on connaît beaucoup de choses sur
les autres dinosaures combien on a deux
est ce qu'on a déjà trouvé beaucoup
d'offres en brionnais avant avant ça
ouais et on a pas mal surtout qu'ils
viennent de chez nous ici en afrique du
sud on n'en n'a pas moins une
soixantaine de noms des oeufs a apprécié
à des embryons dedans je ne sais pas
encore un faucon les scans il ya un nid
par exemple de 34 e qui au canada entre
moment qui va revenir en afrique du sud
et on sait pas s'il ya des embryons de
temps encore donc ça on verra mais wes
inondé aux dinosaures il y en a pas mal
sûr où et comme j'ai dis surtout en
chine
après il y en a pas énormément qui ont
été scannés à mon avis parce que ils
sont ils sont très très petit les
embryons donc comme dit vincent lesca
laboratoire ça fonctionne pas toujours
pour ce genre de choses mais il y en a
il ya déjà eu des articles par un parfum
rico qui a regardé un squelette de
d'embryons dinosaures mais mais pas le
crâne
c'était juste le squelette ou le crâne
d'accord non parce que quand on parle de
f2 dinosaures généralement pas déjà en
france on visualise aix en provence qui
ont énormément 9 mai georges jamais rien
trouvé de dents du moins pas que je
sache
à moins que vous ayez des infos
exclusives met donc à aix en provence et
le sud de la france où on trouve
énormément neuf mais rien du tout dedans
et après il ya effectivement la mongolie
la chine où ils trouvent des oeufs mais
c'est tout du crétacé ya portugal
c'est un ouais ouais ouais l'origne
d'accord il ya des embryons dedans et
après il ya il ya l'amérique du sud qui
est très connu enfin il ya l'amérique du
nord où ils ont quelques eux aussi avec
des embryons des mayas sera notamment
donc c'est du crétacé aussi et
l'amérique du sud c2c de titanosaures
idée donc c'est à ces crétacé aussi donc
voilà qu'est ce que qu'est ce que toi tu
es ya les zones humides aux russes aussi
du showbiz nous au sein du sne s'est mu
aux russes c'est un sauropode m'en faut
si c'est assez vieux c'est ouais environ
d'accord on est de quel âge du coût de
100 millions riches
415 millions d'accord donc sur le
pourquoi le début tout début jurassique
tout au tout début du rallye donc ça ça
c'est quoi sceller ce serait le sait le
plus vieux con il n'y a pas deux il n'y
a pas deux fois avant ça
donc il ya aussi les oeufs de lehfen de
torres qui viennent de chine c'est aussi
un surcoût de mort et ils ont su croire
en un tout petit peu plus jeunes donc
ouais ceux de ma sauce pont et lui se
seraient les plus vieux ou au moins
parmi les plus vieux du monde d'accord
donc ceux d'afrique du sud hier d'accord
c'est eux ils ont quoi comme
caractéristique
comment comment on sait qu'on a
découvert à 9
parce que tu dit on à 60,69 mais comment
on sait qu'on a découvert à 9
on a eu très rond ils sont très rond et
en général y en a plusieurs à côté il y
aura encore des rssi bon on va au city
où ils ont été trouvés c'est aussi en
particulier il y en a encore des oeufs
qui sortent de la falaise et en général
ils sortent pratiquement entier donc ils
sont environ 7 cm de diamètre et c'est
une espèce de boule qui sort comme ça
donc c'est un nodule way est ce qu'ils
sont ni où es tu disais qu'ils sont à
pâques et donc ses cd ni un article qui
est sortie en 2012 qui a regardé ce nid
en particulier donc ce site en
particulier à golden gate et ils ont
trouvé plusieurs nids superposés et
accor l'un à côté de l'autre aussi
et donc il ya une question de fidélité
des masos convenu ce qui revenait chaque
année pour pondre leurs oeufs au même
site
d'accord donc ouais un peu ce que la
même chose que ce qu'on trouve dans le
sud de la france eux oui d'accord
et justement les premières études qui
avaient été faits sur ma sauce pon di
luce est ce que tu peux nous en parler
notamment sur la posture sur ce site web
est donc le premier article est sorti en
2005 aussi par reste étale et ils ont
regardé les uns des changements
proportion entre par exemple le fémur et
l'humérus le bras les bras les jambes
etc et ils ont trouvé que apparemment
les
hébras devenait plus court qu'en comme
asos pony plus grandi c'est donc ça
voulait dire que par exemple quand il
était petit coin est clos il marchait
sur quatre pattes et quand ils
grandissent ils commencent à marcher sur
deux pattes
donc ça c'était en 2005 et le ils ont
utilisé les embryons dans cette étude
aussi donc ils ont mesuré les petits os
des embryons et là ils ont trouvé que
les embryons il marcher à quatre pattes
et papa de pâtes et après en 2010 ils
ont décrit les embryons en détail aussi
donc ça c'était les trois grands
articles sur sur ces embryons si avant
le nôtre qui est sorti à quelques jours
d'accord et du coup le vôtre il apporte
quoi c'est quoi la grande découverte
associé à votre article donc voyage y
avait deux côtés dans notre article à un
détruit kia qui a changé si je peux dire
c'est un donc avant penser que les
embryons de ma sauce money s'il était
mort juste avant un déclin comme ça
qu'on dit alors que maintenant quand les
as cannes et on a regardé tous les os
qui était aussi fait déjà dedans on a
trouvé qu'en fait il ya beaucoup d'eau
qui manquent notamment dans la boîte
crânienne et ils ont aussi deux types de
dents qui sont qui sont présentes et
donc quand on compare ça aux embryons de
vue d'animaux vivants aujourd'hui comme
les tortues et les crocodiles et les
oiseaux on a trouvé qu'en fait les
embryons de masse hosni lui c'était
beaucoup plus jeune que ce qu'on pensait
donc ils sont environ à 60 % de leur or
un cubage qui sont morts pour beaucoup
plus tôt que ce qu'on pense
d'accord donc au lieu d'avoir des
embryons qui était sur le point d'éclore
on a on à moitié moins que ça a presque
en fait presque oui d'accord donc ça
fait ça fait quatre tailles à peu près
donc les crânes
ils sont environ 2 cm et massot
splendidus adultes 1 5 mètres environ
l'animal entier oui mais environ 35 cm
ah oui on sent que vous avez réussi a
estimé un peu à quelle vitesse ça
pouvait grandir
c'est à dire qu'elle sait pas quel âge
euh ouais voilà que quel âge on les
adultes combien de temps il leur faut
pour atteindre l'âge adulte
ouais ouais ça se complique donc un des
plus grands à dire qu'on a il a en effet
misé environ 25 ans 1 425 en un même oui
d'accord donc on n'est pas encore sûr la
croissance explosive des des espèces
plus le plus tardif comme et les grand
sauropode ça dépend si parce que là le
plus vieux le plus grand ce qui aurait
25 ans et que c'est une chose mais ça
dépend à quelle comme la taille ca
augmente et puis après ça plateau c'est
eux
à quel moment ils arrêtent voit un peu
failli grandissent moins vite c'est sais
pas si ce casse mais ya pas mal de
matériel sur des juvéniles et tout ça
capte wade
donc j'ai eu c'était un échappé dans ma
thèse en fait c'était l'histologie de
développement de ma sauce pont dulys
mais on n'a pas encore fini bientôt on
finira par le savoir et donc à un des
trucs qu'on voit et j'avais présenté une
conférence l'année passée c'est on a ce
qu'on appelle t elle maintenant classe
tu es sétif donc comme ils ont éclaté au
sourire donc tu peux avoir des adultes
ou des individus qui ont la même taille
mais ils ont pas le même match
nécessairement donc lors leur croissance
ou la vitesse à laquelle ils
grandissaient ça dépend aussi de
l'environnement dans lequel ils
grandissent d'accord et une différence
au niveau des sexes aussi où ça on sait
pas c'est pas facile
d'accord donc ce qui m'a ce qui m'a pas
choqué mais ce qui m'a frappé aussi
c'est en fait les donc les les eux-mêmes
vont être que tu as d'étudier ont été
découverts dans les années 70 et donc on
est seulement maintenant qu'ils sont
étudiées alors j'imagine que
c'est un truc liés à la technique quoi
il ya jusqu'à l'époque on n'avait pas ce
qu'il fallait pour pouvoir les étudier
donc c'est là que je me tourne vers
vincent puisque vincent est un expert
dans la technique de city scanning donc
d'utiliser les rayons x pour observer
donc est-ce que déjà des ja est ce que
je me trompe pas ce que est ce que c'est
parce qu'à l'époque dans les années 70
on savait pas quoi faire de ces tout
petits yeux parce que là apparemment ils
sont tout petits c'est ça ils sont 100
kw
si le crâne est grand comme ça ça fait 1
9 fois tu disais 7 cm ça fait vraiment
des eaux absolument minuscule est-ce que
c'était un problème de technique à la
base la raison pour laquelle dans les
années 70 ils n'ont pas été étudiés que
le premier papier les 2005
bon allez outre le tout premier vingt
mille et 1979 mais il n'avait pas encore
préparé les embryons et ils les ont que
fait comment préparer en début des
années 2000
ah oui et donc le premier parti que
c'était en 2005 et puis la grande
description c'était 2010 mais c'était
une préparation physique
we will see donc avec le met donc mais
laurent 25 ans presque avant qu'ils
quittent physiquement et préparé je sais
pas et ça c'est une bonne question de
pourquoi ils ont pas fait plus tôt parce
que parce que les oeufs dans une note
aux côtes d'amérique du sud
enfin ça commençait dans des années 90
du coup il après en disant ça passe
tellement vite de sa personne non mais
c'est vrai pour la palme personne ne
s'intéresse à un fossile d'un cool
l'oublier pendant presque dix ans même
si c'est quelque chose d'aussi
intéressant et unique que des embryons
de dinosaures sa vie à nous ça fait déjà
cinq ans que le canadien
mais c'est intéressant parce que c'est
une idée du temps de recherche parce que
tu dis on va effectivement ça fait cinq
ans déjà que tu es allé à grenoble
rencontré vincent pour scanner ces cae
j'imagine que le projet il était plus
vieux que ça encore du coup ce qui là ça
se gâte
well as we 2014 2014 du gouvernent la
particularité de dessins des fossiles en
général parce que ce qui peut être
difficile pour les scanner c'est eux
d'avoir la densité des fossiles qui est
trop proche de la roche et du coup qu'on
veut utiliser un scanner à rayon x
classique puisque on va avoir à
l'hôpital parce qu'on va trouver dans un
laboratoire d'imagerie la difficulté
c'est que c'est la chine fonctionne sur
les contrastes de densité et si si on a
de la roche avec de la roche on peut ne
pas avoir de contrastes du tout donc du
coup c'est là où le synchrotron en
france m est-ce qu'il a des
caractéristiques déjà il produit
beaucoup beaucoup plus de rayons x
donc on a on est sur l'ordre de grandeur
si ces 100 milliards de de rayons x de
plus qu'un scanner médical d'accord
peut-être donné est ce qu'on peut donner
quelques indications donc un synchrotron
c'est un accélérateur de particules et
celui dont tu parles c'est celui de
grenoble
donc le srf pour les intimes d'accord et
donc ça donc on parle d'un anneau qui
fait quelle taille peut comparer à tu
parles d'un scanner classique ou
médicales n'ont qu'à scanner médical ça
rentre dans une pièce mais là on parle
d'un là on parle d'un accélérateur de
particules donc qui fait la taille de du
campus presque entier de oui le
donc les machines on va voir les
scanners d'hôpitaux c'est une première
chose qu'ils sont assez limitées en
terre en nombre d'aureilhan utilisant
voix pour protéger les patients parce
que ce que trouvent les rayons x peuvent
être dangereux pour parce qu'ils
détruisent l'adn par exemple ne
serait-ce que ça donc
donc ces machines là elles sont limitées
pour pour protéger les patients après on
a des machines qui sont qui sont grosses
comme m comme des petits vases en fait
qu'ils vont faire 3 4 mètres dans cette
dimension telle gros cube et qui
permettent de de scanner des objets de 1
cm à 25 cm à peu près et et qui marche
très bien ça celle des machines on a des
centaines et des centaines dans le monde
qui sont utilisés dans l'industrie puis
qu'on trouve de plus en plus dans les
musées les universités aussi notre un
autre grand plaisir est-ce que c'est
plus simple pour nous pour les utiliser
et donc appel aux saints bretons
effectivement c'est un accélérateur de
particules il y en a de plusieurs
tailles suite grenoble où j'ai travaillé
il fait 844 m de diamètre et est du coup
ça s'est tout de suite un autre ordre de
grandeur
quatorze ordre de grandeur dans la
production d'aliments x et une analogie
que j'aime bien nous coule à avoir plus
de rayons x qu'est ce que ça fait c'est
comme quand on prend une photo en plein
jour et une photo la nuit c'est plus
simple en plein jour parce qu'il ya donc
l'appareil avoir plein de rayons x a
fait des meilleures images parce qu'il
ya plein de rayons x et du coup ça c'est
le la première le premier avantage mais
le deuxième c'est une une
caractéristique des rayons x qui
s'appelle la cohérence ça décrit le à
quel point le front dombes de rayons x
est plat et
pour l'intérêt de caen on va avoir ce
front d'onde qui va être déformés par
différents matériaux donc par exemple
des embryons ptérosaures et des
châtiments
même si l'as le lathan site est très
proche
les différences chimiques vont des
formules fronde et se traduire en
interférence rendus capables de mesurer
et donc même si on n'a pas de contraste
visuel on arrive à avoir des
interférences haut à la limite entre les
deux matériaux et donc donc s'appelle le
imaginez-le en contraste de phase et cd
c'est mille fois plus sensibles aux
changements de densité que que
l'absorption classique de ce qu'on a à
l'hôpital parce qu'on a dans les
machines de laboratoire donc c'est très
intéressant pour la paléontologie
parce que du coup on fait des meilleures
images parce qu'on a plus de rayons x
on est beaucoup plus sensible et on est
dans un cas on a besoin de 2 706 ville
de sète et de cette sensibilité pour
mesurer les petites variations de
densité entre l' os fossiles health
aliments et en plus le synchrotron il ya
un faisceau qui est parallèle et c'est à
dire que du coup toute la le
grossissement qu'on fait dans l'image ça
va être comme un microscope c'est
uniquement avec des objectifs
donc on a un matériau qui s'appelle un
scintillateurs qui convertit des rayons
x en lumière visible et daria on appela
lumière visible on peut travailler avec
n'importe quel objectif
donc soit des objectifs photos pour
dégrossir l'image soit des objectifs
microscope pour grossir l'image et
derrière on peut utiliser des détecteurs
ccdh et donc qu'ils sont cons trouve
partout et notamment qui sont développés
soit pour la microscopie soit pour
l'imagerie astronomiques et donc ils
sont dès qu'ils sont développés pour
marché aux fonds pour pouvoir être très
efficace collectés le signal très
rapidement avoir très peu de bruit et du
coup ça sakho loppsi bien avec les
besoins humains donc dans ce type de
blessure donc ça en fait ça permet de
faire des zooms sens sans agrandir la
taille des pixels qu'on est donc avec
les instruments de laboratoire
ils vont avoir ils vont fonctionner sur
sur une géométrie conique le faisceau il
est conique et comme quand on a une
longue torche
si on met la main très proche de la
source l'ombre projetée sur la lune
avait de très bons donc là c'est pareil
en bougeant la le la position de l'objet
entre la source et le détecteur on va
faire un pas de changer le grossissement
pendant un scan et donc on comprend très
vite que si on a enfin la source qui est
un objet physique et qu'on a notre nid
de duff de dinosaures si à un moment on
veut zoomer ou dézoomer juste pour le
crâne bon va plus pouvoir sinon va
cracher le le fossile dans la source et
on risque d'abîmer la source qui serait
d'accord donc ça ça vous permet d'avoir
de la très haute résolution sur d'accord
ce qui est très intéressant pour les
tout petits spécimens et surtout oui
parce que oui enfin même ou alors voir
des choses à très haute résolution mois
un spécimen plus beau mais ça permet de
zoomer sans avoir au moins la contrainte
physique donc
je me retourne vers qui me du coup ça
vous a permis quand même de voir des
trucs assez assez ou fly a notamment
cette histoire de dents est ce que tu
peux nous parler de ces différentes
il ya différents types dentaire alors
que l'embryon in a déjà pas n'est pas
sorti de l'oeuf quoi il a des dents de
lait il a des dents de lait elle est
dans les délais donc ouais donc déjà que
les embryons ils avaient des dents c'est
assez surprenant parce que ça n'avait
jamais été confirmée dans ces embryons
si mais voilà on en trouve deux types
dedans donc il ya un des types c té
d'entrée très simple et triangulaire et
le deuxième type cds dans qui ressemble
plus aux dents qu'on veut qu'on observe
dans les adultes donc avec les commandes
il dit ces régions libération de apple
lancéolées exactement dray est donc mort
au début j'étais je m'y connaissais pas
trop dans les embryons
j'étais très excité je me disais à
peut-être que les les
les petits mangent des choses
différentes mais adultes et c'est
finalement donc il ya beaucoup de
reptiles aujourd'hui comme les gecko par
exemple quand ils sont encore dans leur
zone et aussi ils ont des dandys de
types différents et ils ont une
génération dans qui vont perdre ou
réabsorber quand ils sont dans l'oeuf
et après ils ont une deuxième génération
dans qui sera présent quand il éclore et
donc on pense que ce qu'on voit dans les
embryons de ma sauce pondu c'est la même
chose donc les petites d'entrée
angulaire très simple soit elles
seraient expulsés où elle serait
réabsorber avant avant l'éclosion et
après les dents avec les ces rations ce
serait les dents que les embryons quand
ils déclarent d'accord
et ça ça vous aide à déterminer est ce
que ça vous a aidé à déterminer l'âge
des embryons quand il ou elle est ce que
vous avez utilisé autre chose donc
c'était un un désastre annoncé une
raison aussi pour laquelle on pense
qu'ils sont beaucoup plus jeunes parce
qu'ils sont énormes ils ont encore
beaucoup de ses dents
2 les données les petites d'entrée
angulaire très simple il en a encore
beaucoup donc ils ont encore environ 50%
de leurs danses ont des dents de cette
première génération une génération un
donc savait qu'ils les ont pas encore
perdu les ont pas encore réabsorber donc
ils sont plus jeunes que ce qu'on
pensait après on a aussi regardé les
eaux de la boîte crânienne et les os du
crâne et on peut regarder l'ordre dans
laquelle ces zoos apparaître dans
l'embryon et on les compare à eau
authorised aujourd'hui donc les
crocodiles et tortues et les oiseaux et
ils ont un l'or dans laquelle c'est aux
appareils sont exactement
enfin pratiquement exactement les mêmes
et donc après on peut comparer quel os
sont présents dans nos embryons et on
peut essayer de voir où est ce qu'on
pense qu'ils sont dans leur
développement d'accor et donc vous avez
trouvé un joueur de pattern généralisée
donc quelque chose qui est commun non
seulement dinosaures mais à tous les
reptiles c'est ça ouais hélas les
mammifères ils ont ils ont un patin très
très très similaires c'est aussi un
ballon donc ça va dans quel ordre
grosso modo le sait de l'avant en
arrière derrière l'avant de la plus
c'est avant vers l'arrière les tout
premiers mots qui apparaissent et eux
c'est le les os de la mâchoire la pointe
de la mâchoire et après enfin ces eaux
là en plus grands 10 de la gouverneur et
après enfin les derniers à arriver ça va
être dans la boîte crânienne et dans les
l'articulation de la mâchoire d'accord
donc scellé c'est le coin le plus
compliqué qui arrive en dernier en fait
finalement c'est enfin l'heure la région
la plus complexe qui arrive en dernier
c'est marrant ça comme c'est aussi pour
parce que les cool qu'on revienne à un
embryon de crocodiles boules d'oiseaux
tout ça d'ailleurs mais je dis ça parce
que j'ai fait est âgé plus regardez les
ongles cocody c'est
enfin le cerveau il est gigantesque par
rapport à la boîte de faim et par
rapport au squelette est en train de se
développer et enfin le cerveau il sort
du crâne au début mais en fait tous les
os le d'avoir le cerveau qu'elle a les
options là et au fur et à mesure on va
ça va les eaux vont grandir et ça et
enfin tous grandi en même temps les le
cerveau la boîte crânienne ça m'est
arrivé au niveau au moment de l'éclosion
[Musique]
le la bonne enfin on a le les eaux qui
finissent par englober le cerveau et et
c'est tant mieux en fait avec l'or avec
le cerveau juste mais le cerveau qui se
promènent encore d'accord et c'est mort
du coup je reviens vers qui me suit ce
que tu es de retour donc qu'ils me tuent
nous parlait justement de ses dents je
vais forcément à voir la question dans
les commentaires alors je te la pose à
quoi elles servaient ces petites dents
très simple à hong kong avec y'a pas
longtemps
c'est fait non les est-il d'aujourd'hui
finalement on n'est pas très sûr
pourquoi ils ont ces deux types dedans
donc les crocodiles et gâteaux etc
et d'ailleurs faudrait peut-être devant
l'arbre à 100 parce que j'aimais
beaucoup l'hypothèse vincent en fait
donc quelle votre forte expliqué on a eu
cette question m
le pourquoi pourquoi on est une première
et narration temps qui est très simple
qui ressemble en fait là le type 2 dans
le plus simple qu'on peut faire c'est
juste un petit côté et plus tard on
allait dans les dents qui ressemble qui
sont plus caractéristiques de cette
espèce alors on a ça a l'air ça a l'air
assez complexe le pourquoi ça implique
ça implique pas mal de choses mais il ya
un truc qui semble dans les épaisses où
on voit ça et ce qui est vrai aussi pour
les les embryons de ma sauce prend dit
luce
c'est que les premières dents et cette
génération nul les dom ces petites dents
coniques
elle utilise une une halle c'est quoi
une alvéole bondiront pour les dans une
position dentaire voile afin qu'elles
sont sur les toutes les positions
possibles
elle se développe qu'une position sur
deux d'accord ensuite la la génération
d'un prêt qui ressemble à celle plus
qu'à la forme caractéristique de cette
espèce peu plus un peu plus
caractéristiques elle va utiliser l'eau
de position aussi du coup si on avait
les premières séries sur les aidants
père ben là ça va être les grands pères
et avant le clou juste avant l'éclosion
va voir une troisième série de gens qui
arrivent et qui remplace la première est
donc soit elles sont soit est tombé
absorbé soit elles sont perdues
la première génération nul et du coup on
arrive au niveau de l'éclosion avec
itunes avec un set complet dedans
caractéristiques de l'espace et
fonctionnel parce que les premières sont
trop petites ne reste plus servir à rien
du coup enfin comme tous ces animaux
chez qui on voit les crocodiles et ça
certains les arrêts du coup les ces
dinosaures
enfin au moins chez les espèces modernes
on sait que le remplacement de dentaire
c'est quelque chose de cyclique et qui
une fois que c'est démarrer sa
remplaçante en place et ça remplace de
différentes manières chez différentes
espèces mais dans certains cas ça
remplace une dent sur deux à chaque fois
ce qui est tant mieux comme ça on part
pas toutes ses dents d'un coup on perd
que la moitié et du coup on remplace on
a une nouvelle série on perd notre
métier et ainsi de suite
et donc c'est ce qu'on voit c'est la
mise en place de ce cycle de
remplacement dentaire et qui commence
alors que
que tout n'est pas encore prêt
finalement le cycle le démarrer le cycle
de reproduction dentaire salaire plus
important que d'être sûr on est capable
de faire des vraies dents au débat parce
que le résultat c'est que au niveau au
moment de l'éclosion
grâce à ce rang ce remplacement val
l'animal est d'appliquer dans le
fonctionnel et caractéristiques de
l'espèce
donc en fait il a la garde comme le
premier siècle commence trop tôt il
commence alors que les laisser lula sont
pas encore prêtes à faire des dents
comme il faut d'accord donc ce serait un
un tour de chauffe en fait donc quelques
cents ouais ouais mais alors pourquoi
pourquoi commencer ce rampe ce ce ca
plus je pense c'est il n'y a pas de pain
c'est juste le remplacement il s'est
sûrement aussi qu' il ya des espèces
plus vieille qui avait des dons plus
simple et qui faisait aussi des
remplacements dentaire et peut-être que
l or la première génération elle était
tout à fait caractéristique de leur
espèce et que du coup c'était juste ça
rentre ça commençait le système de
remplacement nanterre et puis de tout et
c'était tout le temps les mêmes dans et
en étant plus complexe chez d'autres
espèces comme fut ma sauce pon di luce
il faut plus de temps pour que que tout
la luz il se met en marche sur dans la
mâchoire pour préparer les la vraie
forme et et au final pas leurs
placements dentaire et commence toujours
au même moment mais il faut quand même
un peu plus de temps pour pour que
toutes les cellules soient bien
fonctionnel que tout levine ce médian
main et baissa pas du tout influencé le
démarrage du remplacement il commence
quand les dents à sont à peu près capcom
les cellules sont capables déjà de
minéralisés de de l'émail et de la
dentine donc ce sera un genre de
reliquat d'un ancêtre qui avaient des
dents très simple et qui pouvait se
permettre de produire des dents très
simple n'importe quand dans sa vie mais
sauf que massot splendidus lui il a des
dents plus compliqué du coup ils
commencent trop tôt et c
et du coup il n'est pas capable de
produire à la morphologie complexe
lancéolées dès le départ donc les donc
ça pas de fonction particulière c'est
plus un accident mais au moins mais
l'important c'est parce que même un
crocodile ça n'a pas dû spécialement
compliqué compliqué elles vont avoir
quelques réunions n'ont même pas partout
elles ont des dents assez simple
chronique mais la première génération
cette génération nul est encore plus
simple ça c'est vraiment des petits
cônes pas courber s'enraye aurait dû
tout et tout petit ça je regardais aussi
la morphologie du crâne et du couture on
voit bien tous les os qui sont isolés
les uns des autres et donc tu t'es qui
me tue t quand même tu sais que tu t'es
quand même bien galéré à tous des
collègues ce que tu peux nous est est-ce
que tu peux nous expliquer comment ça se
passe est ce que est ce que déjà le
crâne tel qu'il est présenté dans le
dans la publication est ce qu il
ressemble vraiment à ça sur le fossile
ou jusqu'à quel point
jusqu'à quel point il a fallu que tu
bosses sur les eaux dans quel état il
était à la base et que combien de temps
il faut pour avoir le résultat que tu as
mis dans la publication avec le tout les
eaux bien organisée cannes lui prendre
quelques heures non ouais on savait
qu'on avait déjà deux craintes
d'embryons parce qu'ils avaient déjà été
physiquement préparer il y en a on voit
du côté y en a un qu'on voit duo après
une des grandes questions qu'on se
posait aussi c est ce qu il y avait
d'autres embryons dans les autres parce
qu on a sept en tout et il y en a que
deux qui ont été qui ont été préparés
malheureusement on en a que trouver un
on a retrouvé un embryon en morceaux
dans
wazemmes 9 mai sinon les quatre zones
the ils s'étaient vus mais avait encore
des os du crâne dans troisième embryons
donc après il fallait reconstruire donc
les trois crânes différents et après
choisir les eaux qui était le les mieux
préservés si je peux dire et après les
remettre ensemble pourra essayer de
remettre les crânes pas d'une façon qui
peut à laquelle il aurait ressemblé en
réalité parce qu'ils sont en tout cas
ils sont tout écraser les crânes donc
donc sachant qu'à la base je n'ai enfin
générer en trois dimensions les
fragments de crâne
c'est pas un processus automatique du
tout non non dont déjà en plus comme ils
sont écrasés ils se touchent tous donc
tous les os on se touche ils sont pas
nécessairement là où il devrait être
comme c'est des embryons ils sont pas
complets 1
donc ouais et ils sont tout petits aussi
donc ça ça a pris du temps et donc faut
tous sélectionnés commence à tapas est
ce que tu peux nous expliquer le
processus qu'on appelle la segmentation
du coloris en tu connaissais mais je
veux que ce soit toi qui le disent ouais
en gros quand corps soient les scans de
vincent qui ont aussi pris énormément de
temps à a procédé il a dû faire beaucoup
de travail dessus
après tu reçois un un stack ou une pile
de ce cadre et il faut passer son temps
à passer dans chaque tranche du scan et
coloriées en fait chaque os d'une
couleur différente
jusqu à ce qu après on puisse prendre
toutes ces tranches et les remettre
ensemble pour avoir un son trône il
mentionné c'est comme des diapositives
comme si on s'amusait à découper en fait
les chaque chaque élément de d'un
milliers de diapositives en fait pour
tout les coller ensemble à la fin ça
fasse un truc en trois dimensions ouais
et comme comme c'est des scans du sens
qu'on trouve
il ya aussi énormément
de data donc oui donc c'est des gros
fichiers en plus oui non mais parce que
c'est juste qu'on peut avoir la fausse
impression que à ces dix dont ils sont
vachement bien préserver ces embryons
quand on regarde la figure que tu as
publié en fait peut avoir la fausse
impression que a dit non on les voit
bien pas si bien que ça
finalement les voit pas si bien que ça
sur l'original ça prend du temps et du
coup il ya un truc aussi avec le crâne
c'est les proportions
enfin les proportions sont pas du tout
celles d'un damaso ce pont dit luce et
adultes non c'est vrai mais l'ont donc
ça ça on le savait on savait déjà parce
qu'on a on a des masses au second dit
luce des bébés dont le crâne sont
environ comme ça 7 7 à 10 cm ils ont
comme comme dans beaucoup des animaux
aujourd'hui ils ont des très très grands
yeux et ils ont amusé autres et
raccourcis aussi et c'est vrai que dans
l'embryon si on regarde ils ont ils ont
un museau très très très raccourcie ils
ont des yeux vraiment vraiment énorme
donc oui les proportions sont très
différentes de celles des adultes qui
auront à mézos beaucoup plus longs ont
été beaux couples type d'accord ok et du
coup ça c'est pareil on va aussi me
poser la question est ce qu'il ya une
fonction derrière ça et quel est le coût
est ce que c'est juste le pattern
généralisée c'est un pattern généralisée
donc les yeux même dans tous les animaux
qu'on voit aujourd'hui les yeux grandi
spam que quand on est on a tous des yeux
beaucoup beaucoup plus grand confort
sionnel mans à la taille du crâne et
c'est pareil dans ma sauce mobile us et
ewen le museau grandi dans tous les
dinosaures derrière après je sais pas si
c'est vrai dans les reptiles
d'aujourd'hui maintenant j'en ai aucune
idée
j'imagine que oui
traditionnellement je demande est-ce que
vous avez quelque chose qui vous tient à
coeur et dont vous vouliez parlé ce que
vous avez quelque chose à ajouter à tout
cela qui me il n'était pas facile à
scanner les oeufs sur des heures et des
heures et des heures et des heures à
faire des moulages et à un médecin est
plein de choses mais la voir après ça
c'est à dire c'est à dire du coup vous
en avez trop dilatoire c'était vraiment
le droit l'oni est presque dix ans mais
il est là ouais voilà quelques
centimètres d'épaisseur et c'est pas
c'est un objet s'est pas du tout adapté
pour un pour un scan de rio x parce que
du coup le principe de la tomographie
c'est de mettre un objet de faire
tourner à 360 degrés et d'enregistrer
des radios et plus on a un signal qui
est relativement homogène pour la pour
l'objet en général mieux c'est donc
l'idéal d'un cylindre et du coup un
objet placé l'inversé de ce qui est
idéal parce que quand on est quand
l'objet il est face aux rayons x et bats
il est relativement fin août l'est qui
laisse passer beaucoup de rayons x et
quand il est dans l'autre sens il est
très épais et il laisse plus passer
grand chose hélas la différence entre
les deux anglais peut parfois causer des
problèmes d'imagerie qui obscurcissent
ce qu'on veut voir à l'intérieur on
était parti sur le principe au départ de
reconstituer un cil 1 et 2 on a moulé
des domiciles un an de plâtre qu'on
devait mettre face devant et derrière le
nid pour que le tout soit cylindrique
et à la limite entre parce que du coup
il ya un brillant et tout ça il fallait
qu'on ait deux couches de protection
parce que vous voulez pas vous voulez
certainement pas des fins et des
spécimens qui sont uniques qui sont
petits qui sont fragiles et du coup
fallait qu'on arrive à mettre quelque
chose entre les deux pour pour pour
pouvoir mettre ses deux domiciles et au
final on arrive enfin à prix c'est un
pris un temps fou je pense à bafoussam
nous apprîmes une journée mais une
journée après paris sa sur des spécimens
aussi aussi délicat est aussi unique
c'est six journées stressantes
c'est stressant et bien voilà qu'on ait
un qui me hante aise et moi je ne post
hoc cf
personne n'a envie d'avoir la
responsabilité d'avoir cassé et du cou
et du coup on a préparé ça on a réussi
ses techniques
on a bien réussi à bien travaillé on a
réussi à faire exactement ce que vous
voulez sauf qu'au final ça peut marcher
et des images était encore pire quand
les images étaient elle était elle était
moche ouais et je pense que c'est
possible que le problème vienne du
plâtre qui qui est microporeux qui est
plein de petites bulles et du coup sacré
plein d'interférences et du coup ça les
images et c'était horrible
du coup on a tout enlevé l'année comme
ça on n'a rien
après on avait essayé avec l'été les
petites billes et anvers oui qu'ils
utilisent sont là et bâtons et puis ça
aussi ça va pas marcher puis finalement
je crois le 3 la troisième fois on a dit
bon écoute on va juste essayer de le
mettre comme ça et puis alors ça ça a
super bien marché on aurait peut-être dû
commencer avec je crois qu'on a perdu
cinq jours environ ou quatre jours à
essayer de les scanner de façon
différente sait par expérience quand on
fait des crânes d'hominidés c'est ça a
toujours bien marché quand il était bon
et qu'on mettait débit de fin du sable
les et le signal
c'est logique les terriers d'afrique du
sud est pareil c'est comme ça et du coup
on est parti sur mais markov à saint
silain on va faire ça bien avec
mais bon c'est pas ça a marché
c'est ouais c'est une longue
c'est une chouette aventure tu as et ça
c'est quand on vient quand on arrive au
moment où il faut qu'on parle à la
presse et qu'il faut qu'on d'accous faut
qu'on se dise quand est ce que vous
l'avez scanner 2015 une petite claque
mais mais ouais non c'était une sté
copains c'était compliqué c'est une
étude qui est compliquée mais qui libère
gratifiant c'était compliqué de les
scanner c'était compliqué de préparer
les données pour kimi ça a dû me prendre
six mois après six mois de travail pour
que kimi et les données et qui me vient
de passer par ici moi pour la
segmentation qu'après on ad on a dû
trouver les scans des autres aussi donc
ça aussi ça a pris du temps et du coup
voilà c'est un projet qui en gros entre
le moment où on commence à guérir les
données il faut presque un an un an et
demi avant d'avoir enfin de matériel qui
va du travail et e
du coup la voilà puis après toutes les
difficultés de la publication ça me
paris ça fait 900 un processus qui prend
du temps on est tous un peu de devoir
maintenant tous ces belles images dans
les médias où c'est très gratifiant
c'est un peu de travail qui ça et je le
regarde et me mais si je le dis pas ça
marche pas
cotis ok donc oui félicitations pour
votre publication encore une fois
c'était donc c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment du très très beau travail et ça
donne
ces images ça donne vraiment envie de le
savoir tout ce qu'il ya derrière et
j'encourage très fortement nos auditeurs
à aller voir à aller lire cette
publication qui est temps d'accès qui
est en open access donc vous ne paierez
pas pour la télécharger
et ben voilà je vous dis merci beaucoup
pour m'avoir accordé de votre temps en
cette période de confinement et puis je
dis à tout le monde
à très bientôt et joyeuses pâques ciao
na li
[Musique]